uh the next speaker does not drink
coffee but is made up of equal parts
pizza and ice cream i'm happy to
introduce jared lander
all right thank you very much cass it's
been a pleasure knowing you through all
these years as well
so assuming everyone can see my screen
here
and
great
so today
i'm going to talk to you about
using gpus with r
so that means we're going to talk about
bitcoin
okay all right just kidding we're not
going to talk about bitcoin i had to do
that what we're really going to talk
about is dogecoin
all right that's the last one i promise
you we're not going to do that again uh
we're going to talk about gpu for
scientific computing
particularly stats and machine learning
so when i say that i don't mean
just deep learning there's many other
things besides deep learning we could
use the gpu for
and we're going to dive into many of
those things we can do
so before we do that though we have to
ask why the gpu why am i giving a whole
talk about gpu why are people so excited
about these things that are meant for
video games
and it all comes down to cores
a typical cpu
might have
six cores 12 cores 20 if you have a
really great expensive cpu up near 100
cores
but a gpu can give you thousands of
cores
the price per core is lower
and this allows you to massively
parallelize your work
you might ask why can't a cpu have
thousands of cores
that's because
cpu cores need to be general purpose
whereas gpu cores each core is doing the
same thing at the same time well
different times maybe
so they're different types of core so
you couldn't just get a cpu of thousands
of cores
then you might fairly ask well why do we
need so many courses to begin with why
do we need so many of them what are we
going to do with them
for me particularly it's going to be
programming and machine learning
for programming that mainly means in my
context matrix algebra and massively
parallel loops
and for machine learning that can be
deep learning boosted trees or even
bayesian methods yes we can speed up
bays using a gpu
so let's see what's available to us on
cram
crane has a whole task view system
that's a human curated system of
different packages to use for different
use cases
and it lists for the gpu gpu-r gpu tools
g matrix magma and a few others
so let's take a look at some of those
like gpur
that was removed from cran
and gpu tools that was removed from cran
gmatrix was also removed from crayon
magma was removed from crayon
our pud removed from crayon
cuda bay's reg removed from crayon
it looks like they haven't updated that
task view in a while and all that's left
are opencl perm gpu torch and keras
and torch wasn't even listed i just
added that to the list myself
bioconductor has a few more gpu packages
but my world mostly lives in cran and
it's very hard to use a gpu packaging
crane
only out of these four only opencl is
general purpose
of course there are more options not on
crayon and not on bioconductor and we'll
look at some of those
but before we can do that we need to
install cuda
this is a general purpose programming
toolkit for computation on a gpu
specifically an nvidia gpu
actually just saw today there was some
research about porting cudaco to a
risc-v processor but it's very difficult
to do
also very difficult to do is installing
cuda
now my company is an nvidia partner and
i still have a very hard time installing
cuda you need to install the correct
linux headers download a pin file fetch
a gpg key add an app source and finally
install cuda which also installs nvidia
it's a lot of work and i had to patch
together these instructions from many
different sources including the official
nvidia instructions which
led to a lot of bad alleys for me
you might just want to use a pre-built
docker container or a cloud vm your life
might be a lot easier
for now we're going to focus on
programming and machine learning and
we'll start with programming
we'll look at different frameworks for
writing custom code on the gpu and the
first one we see will be opencl
this allows you to write generic code
that can run on different devices it can
run on a cpu run on a gpu and asic
different ways to do this
before you can use it you need to
install both a linux library or a
windows library it's oclicd opencl dev
and then install the r package opencl
from crayon
once you have everything installed and
by the way this assumes you have your
gpu software installed underneath
you then can go ahead and write your
first opencl function which is actually
not a function but a kernel so we put
underscore underscore kernel in front of
it
the return type has to be void because
it won't return anything it will
actually put whatever your output is in
the first argument which we're calling
output which is a numeric vector and
it's global because it's a memory buffer
that's why we put underscore underscore
global in front of it
the second argument has to be
the length of that output
and then you can give further arguments
like your inputs which can either be a
scalar like in length or
a
vector now when i call it a vector it's
actually a memory buffer and it i call
it a memory buffer because it's generic
it can live on any memory source it
could be a memory buffer on the gpu or
on the cpu
and then you write your function right
here i'm building a distance function
but notice there are no for loops
usually if you build a pairwise distance
function you need nested for loops
there are none
because i set i to get global id
and that knows that there are
out length outputs
and it will automatically parallelize
your code across the gpu or other device
so we get to write our code the last
line in there vectorized it looks a lot
like our code it looks like vectorized r
code
and it's all taken care for us
parallelization will be taken care of
for us
now that we have our function written we
actually need to set up where it's going
to do the computation
so we open up the opencl package
and we look up the platform which in our
case is nvidia cuda
given that platform we have a device
it's an nvidia geforce gtx it's a gaming
gpu
and then our compute context will be on
this device with that platform that's
how we create the ctx with ocl context
now that we have that we can
make the kernel available to us in r so
we call ocl simple kernel we give it the
compute context
the name of our kernel which has to be
the same as the name in the code you
wrote and then the actual code as a
character string
that we wrote on the previous slide
now i'm going to generate some random
data just so we have something to work
with here
and we generate
two vectors of random normals
i would like to put this in a matrix but
this function required it to be a vector
and i could have you know written the
input and the output to be a little bit
different but for
ease i just made two vectors
and then i convert these r vectors into
cl buffers because it's a memory mapping
yes we're duplicating the data in memory
but we have to live with it
we can then pass this data along with
our kernel into ocl run and that will
run the kernel for us on the data
this gives us back the distance matrix
and it works
now you are limited to gpu memory so
make sure you have a big enough gpu for
your data
and opencl can be a little clunky and
you're limited to vectors so it's a
little difficult to use
so i want to turn to something that i
find a little bit easier rcp rcpp
arrayfire this is like rcpp but for the
array light the arrayfire library
this is a tensor library for gpus
and tensors are just arrays so we are
essentially doing matrix multiplication
it's like armadillo for the gpu and the
code is mostly vectorized like regular r
to use this you first need to install
arrayfire which you could do by
downloading the shell script and then
executing it with pseudo permissions and
then putting the location of this
executable this binary into a config
file
so there's a lot of ways to do this you
could do it with apt that didn't work
for me with many tries so i switched to
the shell script
you then need to install the r package
but it's not on cram so you use drat to
set up takana's github profile as a repo
and install rcpp arrayfire from their
repo
and now we can write functions that look
a lot like that are c plus
you do that with normal rcpp syntax you
tell it you want the rcpp arrayfire
library and you declare a function to
have an af array output which is
essentially like an r array and the
input is going to be an rcpp arrayfire
array which is a lot like a r array or
an r matrix
i'm writing a distance function again so
i have two loops
i could have unrolled these double loops
into a single loop but for ease of
coding i just made it two for loops
you'll see the first for loop is g4
that's actually a parallel for loop
that's going to be run in parallel on
the gpu and i'm going through each row
of the matrix
in parallel and for each of those rows i
will sequentially check all the other
rows against it
again i could have wrote this with a
single parallel loop but just for ease
of illustration i did a nested for loop
and you can't have nested parallel loops
you can only have one nested one
so then i create some data with a matrix
a two column matrix and i call this
distance function i wrote and it gives
me back an answer
you still have to move the data from the
cpu memory to gpu memory which isn't
awesome but is doable
the big problem is this package rcpp
arrayfire hasn't been updated in 6 years
so that might give you pause using this
so rather than writing external code
let's write r code
all our matrix algebra calculations
depend on a linear algebra routine
typically atlas open blast mkl
so nvbus is a cuda matrix algebra
library that is a drop-in replacement
for whatever you already have in your
computer
and then you can use regular r functions
on the gpu to do this you need to set up
a config file telling it where the log
file is where your cpu blast is which
gpus to use
that's fine
then when you launch r you set
environment variables like ld preload
pointing to nv blasts
and you point to the config file and
then you launch r
there's a way to do this of our studio
in our studio server but i'm doing this
just at the terminal for now i was
inspired by your own talk to do
everything in the terminal
so then you create your matrices i
create an a matrix and a b matrix and i
transpose a and multiply it against b
now
this all happens in the gpu when you
create the matrix it gets loaded in gpu
memory when you do the multiplication
the gpu is doing the calculations all
for you nothing's in cpu right now
if you want to calculate the distance of
a matrix
you create the matrix it lives on the
gpu you call the dist function the same
dist function you would use in base r
but now the calculations happen on the
gpu you didn't need to write any special
code it all happened for you
and that's pretty nice
but i like to see what we have next it's
torch and it's not just for neural
networks it's also a general purpose
matrix algebra library that's been
highly optimized and i think it's going
to be easier to use than the regular r
functions because you need to worry
about the blasts with torch you don't
need to worry about that
so you install torch the r package which
is on crayon
and then you use the torch package to
install the torch libraries and type
11.1 means use the gpu is using cuda
11.1 then i could just check is the is
cuda available and if it is you're good
to go
now this might not work great if you're
using r e and v you have to jump through
a few hoops to make that work
so repeating what we just saw in base r
i'm going to create some random normal
matrices using torch normal and i'm
going to move them to the gpu using
dollar sign cuda
there is an argument to torch normal to
put it straight onto the gpu but i'm
getting a weird bug that i've been able
to replicate on a few different
environments so for now i use dollar
cuda to move it to the gpu
now that my two matrices are on the gpu
i could transpose them by do using
dollar sign t and then do matrix
multiplication with matte mole
that's it same idea we saw base r but
using torch
if you want to fit a distance matrix i
create a matrix in torch on gpu memory
and i call torch pdist instead of the
base r function dist
works great you are limited to gpu
memory you typically have less gpu
memory than cpu memory but it's really
great it's really fast
so what do we learn so far about
programming
is that you're mainly going to be doing
matrix algebra
and you should really just use torch
it's the easiest and fastest both in
terms of computer time
and human time so i recommend that even
over using mv blasphemy base r
so now let's turn our attention to
machine learning and we'll look at a few
methods deep learning boosted trees and
bayesian regression
and we'll pick up where we left off with
torch
we're going to use this for deep
learning now
we'll start with the credit data out of
the model data package and we'll make
sure it's a typical
and our goal for the rest of the talk
will be to predict status
it's like a good data scientist will use
our sample to split it into a training
set and test set and like a bad data
scientist we're going to use a test that
is validation also
we then write a recipe to prepare our
data and we're going to write a
different recipe for every single method
we're using for torch we're going to
impute missing data we'll standardize
our numerics we'll turn our categorical
data into dummy variables even though we
really should do an embedding for now
we'll just use dummies and we need to
make the output an integer with one and
two those are the two levels one and two
we then use a torch data set
we create a torch data set i should say
this is going to have an initialization
step that will take our data and do the
pre-processing turn it into torch
tensors
and it creates a function for
slicing through individual parts of the
data
the data still lives on the cpu we
haven't moved into the gpu yet we'll get
to that later
we initialize the torch data set and
then we use a torch data loader that is
going to allow us to iterate through we
don't fit the model on the entire data
at once we fit the model on 64 rows of
data at a time or however many rows you
want we are going to do 64 rows of data
for our case
now that we have our data loader we
design our neural network this is a
fairly simple one yet it's still kind of
complex we have three hidden layers
we use the relu activation function
because
deep learning is just matrix algebra
again and again all the power comes from
the activation functions which gives you
non-linearity leading to extreme
nonlinear modeling we also define some
dropouts so we have some regularization
and this is our model took a bit of
effort to build this
now that it's designed we actually have
to instantiate it we tell it how many
nodes in each hidden layer how big the
data coming in is and we
sort of compile we're not literally
compiling it but we're getting it ready
we then take our model and move it over
to the gpu of dollar sign cuda
we are moving the weights over because
these weights are giant arrays of
numbers that we're going to matrix
multiply and that's all going to happen
on the gpu so the weights now live on
the gpu
we then iterate over our data we need
nested for loops we make multiple passes
or epics over the data and then we make
multiple iterations on the data within
each epoch we do 64 rows at a time
so each time we grab 64 rows we move
those 64 rows over to the gpu with
dollar sign cuda
we do this
because we only want a little bit of
data on the gpu once because you're
doing these giant matrix calculations
it's going to take a lot of memory you
don't want to put all the data on there
we do this for the training set we do it
for the validation set we do it for both
the predictors and the outputs move them
all to the gpu and then do the matrix
multiplication torch model is where the
matrix multiplication happens
now this was a lot of boilerplate double
for loops luckily there's an easier way
the luz package which is on cran
it handles it all for you handles the
validation handles the epics iterating
over the data
you set it up with your optimizer with
your loss function any metrics you want
to calculate you set your parameters
like the different sizes and hidden
layers and you are ready to go
you want to fit your model you just call
the fit function
plus handles all the loops for you and
if a gpu is available it automatically
uses the gpu so you don't have to worry
about it it's all taken care of for you
nothing special you need to do
so that's deep learning let's turn to
boosted trees particularly xg boost it
is a great algorithm for doing
predictions
and it has gpu capability
though not on cran you need to install
it yourself using pre-built binaries you
download the binary from the github repo
install some other r packages you need
and then you install this pre-built
binary which has gpu capability using
rcmd install from the command line
you used to have to install it yourself
with cmake
and luckily you don't have to anymore
and i want to take partial credit for
encouraging them to do this i put up a
get up issue and they very quickly made
it happen
and that's just beautiful about open
source
if you ask nicely you sometimes get what
you need it's really great
so we build another recipe we no longer
need to do amputation
and our outcome is now a zero based
integer
we then
build our input and output matrices and
since it's xg boost we get to use a
sparse matrix for the inputs which could
speed up computation time and can make
it take up less base memory
since it's xg boost we need to build a
special xgb.d matrix object which holds
your predictors and your outputs
together in one object
and then we can fit the model of
xgb.train
and all you need to do to flip this over
to using the gpu instead of the cpu is
say tree method equals gpu hist and gpu
id equals the id of your gpu in this
case the zero if gpu
that's it
now this is a boosted tree so the trees
are still grown sequentially but within
each tree the search for the best splits
can be done in parallel on the gpu
the issue with
xg boost is you have so many parameters
you need to too you need to tune all
them find the best of them
so we'll look at tidying models which
will let us do that for which will
handle that for us
so first we need to do some boilerplate
we create the
cross the k fold cross validation right
here the v fold cross validation
we then use parsnip to set our model
specification we're using boosted tree
and we're tuning over trees tree depth
and sample size
and then when we set the engine we can
pass engine
engine specific parameters
into the model in this case params is
for xg boost and has an option tree
method gpu hist like we just saw
we then set up our recipe and for tidy
models it expects it to be a factor for
the outcome
we combine the recipe and the
specification into a workflow
i update the parameters because i don't
like the defaults
and then we set up a
parallel cpu cluster
and then we call tune grid so there's
now two levels of parallelization
you
iterate over the tuning parameters on
the cpu and then each time you fit the
model you do that on the gpu so we're
parallelizing both the cpu and the gpu
to get massive speed up when i did this
for the first time i texted max queen
hey look i used both the gpu and cpu in
parallel with tidy models and he said oh
great someone asked me if that was
possible
i'm the person that asked him if it was
possible so i'm glad it works
so now we turn to bayes
and once again this uses opencl
run anywhere coded and thankfully the
stand team has done all the work for us
this time we install the cl info
linux library and we find out where our
platform and our
device are both nvidia cuda it's a video
cuda platform and nvidia gtx gpu
but we don't use r stand we use a newer
package command stand r which is not on
cran yet so we install that from the
stand repo then we use the command stand
r package to install stand itself and i
use four cores to make the installation
go faster
i write a standard logistic regression
using stan
but instead of using bernoulli logit as
my outcome i use bernoulli logic glm
because that takes better advantage of
the gpu speedups
when i compile and yes you compile your
stand models
i set cpp options to say use opencl
i then fit another recipe because now my
outcome needs to be 0 1 again i put the
data into a list for stan
and then when i do my sampling
i say opencl ids equals the vector zero
zero the zero if platform and the zero
with device
and now
all the matrix calculations will be done
in the gpu
i'm still doing four parallel chains on
my cpu in parallel and i'm doing all the
matrix calculations on the gpu
now this takes up a lot of gpu memory so
we have four chains we're doing all
these calculations on the gpu so make
sure your gpu is big enough but we can
get a pretty nice speed up now thanks to
two levels of parallelization
it's really really great
so we learned a lot about what we need
to do
the first is that cuda is the linchpin
it all depends on having cuda installed
and it is very hard to work with so i
highly recommend using docker if
possible or even better a cloud vm
that's all set up for you
and there's not a lot of gpu enabled
packages left on crayons you have to
do this yourself
in terms of custom programming
you're pretty much going to stick to
matrix algebra because that's what gpus
are great at
and i recommend just using torch life
will be better if you just use torch
that was the easiest way for me to work
with it
and when you want to fit machine
learning models
you're going to want to use pre-built
binaries
and you should really use docker
lifeless better views docker images
pre-built ones
and it's fairly easy to switch from a
cpu to the gpu it's usually just an
option that you need to change it's not
so bad
but your speed gains may vary so you
need to ask is it worth installing cuda
thank you very much
all right
i now have the pleasure of staying on
stage to
introduce
my next speaker
so the next speaker
i met
about as long as i met kaz